professeur vous aurez du mal à le croire
on m'a envoyé vous trouvez depuis le
futur dans 50 ans ne leur fait pas
encore une fois s'il vous plaît
laissez-moi finir début les sentinelles
ne cibler que les mutants ensuite à
aider tout le monde
je suis venu de loin pour nous guider
nous rassembler les x men on a besoin de
bourrer dit à celui qui vous envoie que
celui occupé celui qui m'envoient c'est
vous
il faudra s'y mettre tous pour arrêter
cette guerre
c'est toi le fauve je comprends rien ce
que vous me dites mais tu as de la
poigne pour un gamin je vous ai dit de
partir
on va être très potes tous les deux mais
tu le sais pas encore on te veux
mystique pourquoi lorsque tu es une
belle guerre injuste aux acheteurs prix
il nous faudra magnéto aussi cet homme
c'est un monstre
il est emprisonné dans les tréfonds du
bâtiment le mieux gardé de la planète
je connais un gars ce sera un jeune
homme maintenant il est fascinant à
l'emmerdeur aurait une évasion quoi tu
sais que c'est défendu seulement si tu
te rigoler
charles
content de te vois aussi mon vieil ami
je sens qu'on va se marrer
un nouvel ennemi vient d'apparaître
aguer nouvelles armes nouvelles
désormais tout notre avenir
dans le futur est-ce que je m'en sors
non